Britt's Harry and Megan Markel new dad
Harry enjoying some me-time and marking
on a little business and pleasure over
in Italy Harry looked happy and upbeat
and not at all like he's been missing
sleep since Archie's birth he made a
solo appearance today in Rome at a
charity polo event his friend polo star
nacho figueras says becoming a dad has
made a huge impact on Harry being a fire
always changes you know he seems to be
very very happy I think this is a very
exciting part of his life he's loving it
while Harry was an Italy Megan stayed
home with their newborn seems the
Duchess is doing most of the work
herself her mom Dorio Ragland returned
home to Los Angeles after nearly five
weeks in the UK helping out this is a
hole and this Memorial Day weekend you
can check out a TV movie version of
Megan and her mom in lifetimes Harry and
Megan becoming royal in this new scene
we see the imagined moment when Harry
found out he was a dad to be there have
been a couple different baby bumps that
we've been wearing which has been really
fun and interesting and just bizarre
because I'll forget sometimes that I
have it on and then you're like walking
out of the trailer to go and get a
coffee or something and someone that's
not a part of the film sees me and I'm
like oh they like think I'm pregnant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]